نعود الى منتدى الرياض الدولي الانساني في
نسخته الثالثه لمتابعه فعاليه رياضيات لست
جيدا ان يكون من
الاحياء من السياسيه والشيء الاخير اتمنى
ان ارى السلام في اليمن
خلال سنتين انا اريد ان احل كل الصراعات
وان نتمكن من فعل هذا وان نزيد مجتمع
التبول التبرع
وان نعزز الرقمنه
والذكاء الاصطناعي وجمع البيانات وتحسين
الوضع الاوليات بناء على البراهين
اتى اامل لشيء واحد هو ان فجوه التمويل
الانساني سوف تتقلص وتختفي وهذا يمكن ان
يحدث بطريقتين اساسيتين الاول ان نزيد
التمويل عن طريق توسيع
قاعده البيانات والشيء الاخر عن طريق
تقليل المساعدات الانسانيه عن طريق منع
النزاعات وحل القائمه
اتمنى ان نرى تركيزا اكبر وان نرى تعاونا
اكثر لان التحديات هائله والمصادر محدوده
هل اظهرتم تقديركم للاعضاء
وايضا من اجل تغلبنا على المشاكل تقنيه في
الصوت
هل لا تغادرون القاعه ونبدا الجزء الثاني
من الحوار
اذا تبعنا جانبا من مناقشات منتدى رياض
الدولي الانسانيه كان هناك كلمه للمبعوث
الاممي مارتن جرافيس سنذكر بانه مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه ينظم هذا المنتدى